[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro d'
envies de lecture d'un tel dit wolf
comment ça va tennis alors va donner
plein de conseils des conseils de
jeunesse avec valérie tuiles bonjour
vous avez de la librairie du cadre
responsable du rayon jeunesse donc ses
jo de la jeunesse et votre c'est votre
truc
et puis et puis nous sommes avec un
éditeur jean charles lajoie dit d'un
jour bonjour alors vous allez nous
parler et vous éditez des dépôts là vous
allez parler de nous parler d'un des
polars que vous éditez mais aussi d'un
livre culte et d'un autre roman policier
qui n'est pas de votre maison d'édition
mais peut-être n'a t on commence avec
les livres de jeunesse commence avec les
livres jeunesse et je laisse la parole à
notre libraire
bonjour à tous je commence avec le livre
qui est le premier roman d'une autre
hills qui s'appelle célia samba qui à 22
ans qui a gagné en fait le concours d'un
premier roman qui s'appelle donc le no
future
elle les élèves infirmières au fait au
départ et elle s'est intéressée aux sans
abri plus particulièrement est donc en
fait dans ce roman
elle nous propose deux personnages une
jeune étudiante qui est en première
année de droit qui elle vit en
colocation avec ses cousins et elle vit
dans la région parisienne mais ces
études se passe sur paris et en fait
tous les jours il fait le trajet pour
venir en prenant nouvelle rumeur comme
des millions de gens bras croisés des
sans-abri une personne on n'est pas très
loin de noël et en fait elle va acheter
une crêpe et en se disant bien c'est un
geste que je peux faire pour cette terne
sans ce jeune homme
sauf que bah finalement une soeur jane
une sorte de gêne une honte je ne sais
pas comment définir exactement son
sentiment elle passa à côté tout annuel
rubinel rubinel rue mais elle s'y met
c'est pas possible je peux pas faire ça
donc non malheureux a crush est une
crêpe bien chaude et elle va le donner à
ces à ce jeune homme
ce jeune homme c'est triste un tristan
il a 21 ans il vit dans la rue depuis
pas mal de temps on n'a pas tout de
suite les raisons de ce qu'ils l'ont
amené à vivre dans cette rue mais on a
vraiment les vocations de ce quotidien
faire mendier c'est d'avoir de l'argent
pour pouvoir se payer une nourriture et
s'est trouvé un lieu où il sera serein
tranquille on parle des associations qui
viennent en aide aux sites ces jeunes et
donc en fait un lien va se développer
entre ces deux de deux êtres ll est pas
très en confiance avec elle même elle
est une jeune fille est pas voilà qui
mentent de certitudes qui manque de
confiance en elle et en ayant fait ce
geste en fait ça va le changer
complètement son nom de sa vie ce roman
m'a touché il est émouvant que ce n'est
pas qu'une histoire vanité c'est une
histoire d'amour aussi qui va se
développer
on va voir donc tous les côtés qu'on
peut le trouver dans la rue la drogue la
prostitution vin que l'on pourra être
utile et j'ai hâte parce que c'est pour
qu'elles agissent à partir de 14 à
partir de 14 ans et jusqu'à à bombay je
vous l'avais lu j'ai 15 ans
dire que les romands à dos il ya un âge
minimal pour certains en f1 parce que
certains sujets mais on peut lire la
lutte pour lui a par exemple s'est pas
trouvé tout à fait son bonheur pratiqué
est d'actualité
alors il ya des livres je crois pour des
enfants moins un mois forewheel jeunes
en les visitant et on passe à 85 ans et
donc le petit l'album que je vais vous
montrer c'est le plus petit yak petit ia
qui est un premier album de l'ue frazer
et kate england katyn là elle a déjà
fait d'autres illustrations dont des
albums qui m'ont voilà qui m'avait
beaucoup plu qui s'appelait n'oublie pas
ton rêve que j'avais vraiment beaucoup
aimé et donc dans cette histoire nous
allons avoir une histoire de l'art ti
gars qui sait une petite claque tout
petit chaque elle est tellement petit
qu'elle se sent trop différente ce pas
normal ce pas juste se fera livrer
tellement drôle grande serre comme les
autres galoper enfin valoir elle a plein
de talent mais elle n'a aucune confiance
en elle sa mère lui dit mais tu as le
temps de grandir
ne t'inquiète pas tu vas trouver malgré
tout elle va tenter de faire des choses
dont elle va essayer de manger 5 fruits
et légumes conseils à vos enfants
elle va demander l affaire
d'entraînement physique parce que l'on
sait jamais le sport ça aide aussi à
faire agrandir et si elle va aussi lire
pour se cultiver
parce que dans les livres on en apprend
beaucoup de choses donc j'aime beaucoup
les petits jeunots iliaque et la fourmi
ya qui lui arrive comme aj boucle d'or
et les trois y adapter oiac c'est
totalement adapté aurillac et donc une
autre petite héroïne
malgré tout on ne va pas mentir tout le
temps on va laisser faire son âme mais
elle n'a pas réussi
sauf qu'un jour où va l'appeler à l'aide
parce que il ya chine h et des concerts
en haut de la montagne avant goût des
sommets enneigés
tout le monde court font ce pour lui
demander de l'aide
artix hagerty parce que c'est la plus
petite et donc elles risquent de gloin
soulever voilà et elle a peut-être cet
espoir de finalement de réussir à
accéder à ce lieu et donc elle va y
arriver elle va sauver notre ami achille
et elle surtout elle va comprendre que
chaque temps de vie est égale 1 chaque
moment
grand tiers est donc le la phrase que
j'ai voulu garder c'est la grandeur peut
prendre d'autres formes n'est pas obligé
d'être très grand pour finalement faire
des grandes choses on peut être tout
petit et réussir à faire des belles
choses dernier président de la
république sont vous cet album
les images sont pétillantes sont colorés
c'est en plus d'époque avec le sommet
enneigé enfin tout ce qu'on peut
retrouver non c'est ça la différence ça
vous donne pleins de joie et plein de
bonne humeur 2000 tr 10 jours ça marche
bien le le rayon jeunesse voleuse rouaix
toujours bas surtout dans cette période
je pense que les salles ont besoin de
données
voilà une ouverture sur le monde une
manière de se cultiver qui est très très
sympa fin juin il ya tellement
d'ouverture est tellement de choix
le feu trouve qu'un rayon jeunesse peut
permettre vraiment beaucoup de choses
donc l'arrêt très lourd cela vous pour
paver du canal un très grand rayon
jeunesse le rideau sépare de célia sont
bas et le plus petit yagg de l'ue frazer
et kate inle je voudrais juste rajouter
la rue qui ne sais pas il y à deux fins
alternatives selon votre envie vous avez
une pause par un côté positif un côté de
bêtises et bien sûr c'est aussi ça qui
fait son originalité et voilà c'est bien
yoyo et gouvenou l'ubs a eu en fait elle
commence par la plus difficile et vous
êtes pouvez la sauter est d'accord on
peut aller après la page 239 si je dis
pas de bêtises qu'est ce qui vous amène
à la fin alternative alors on va passer
aux roses adultes avec pourtant
peut-être on va commencer par un roman
culte kaki votre votre livre de chevet
si je peux dire jean charles lajoie dit
qu'ils étaient dues à un jeune romancier
qui est john kennedy o'toole et c'est la
conjuration des imbéciles
voilà vraiment attention le meilleur
livre que j'ai jamais lu un roman
totalement extraordinaire foisonnante
reculons et au delà de cette histoire
une histoire d'un trentenaire très malin
et très très gros
je me suis lié par sa propre personne
mais qui a une vie intérieure absolument
fabuleux et un regard sur le monde
extrêmement à série c'est un roman qui
est très drôle un peu désespéré par
moments bien évidemment mais c'est
vraiment leur enrôlement le plus drôle
c'est qu'on puisse lire l'essai surtout
l'un des meilleurs jamais écrit on est
toujours dans la catégorie des meilleurs
jamais faiblir des états unis fait
partie des dix meilleurs livres il a eu
toutes les laiteries possibles et
inimaginables et d'histoire de cet
auteur est absolument poignante et
tragique ce john kennedy toole écrit ce
livre
il était de faire publier vrai tous les
tous les éditeurs l'envoyer balader
donnant ce truc n'a aucun intérêt et
dionne qu'elle est du tout d'espoir ma
vie des aînés spectre iman si on ne
reconnaît pas comme écrivain du coup la
vie ne vaut pas d'être vécue en tout cas
su passer pour ce monde et s'est suicidé
donc c'est absolument rien et sa mère
senna a retrouvé le manuscrit dans son
dans sa table de skrei a lu le livre et
s'est dit mais se dit prête
effectivement un chef-d'oeuvre et la con
c'est à parcourir les états unis et elle
a trouvé un éditeur qui vient dîner oui
ce livre est absolument génial de publi
c'est un éditeur de taille moyenne
oui je dois après un des plus grands
éditeurs américains à new york à
racheter des droits est devenu un succès
absolument colossal
donc il ya un côté poignant à savoir que
ce livre était peut-être 50 livres à
avoir lu dans sa vie et l'auteur n'a pas
connu ce sucre est absolument
extraordinaire cette terrible phrase en
robe à lire toutes affaires cessantes
vraiment alors on va passer un polar
maintenant que nous nous recommander
celui de pierre couche erik zabel
l'assassin qui met paul beau as c'est un
drôle de titre il a eu le prix du quai
des orfèvres
il ya quelques années
breton va pas que le breton mais en fait
qu'il travaille beaucoup en bretagne
très intéressant et pierre touchard l
auteur ni c'est un ancien flic il était
commandant de police qui l'a notamment
après que nous en parle s'il a passé une
dizaine d'années à la police judiciaire
de versailles
donc c'est quelqu'un de c'est quelqu'un
du cru si je puis dire
et donc c'est un écrivain qui avait pris
du président et des orfèvres en 2010 est
un très très grand écrivain un très bon
très bon auteur de polars et alors je
vous en parle parce que au delà de lui
qui est vraiment intéressant et publics
notamment dans une maison d'édition que
tout change nous connaissent ou
reconnaît ce sont les éditions du talent
et mon oui mais les mauvaises
prestations pas rothen qui fait un
véritable malheur mais à paris on est
entre parisiens ont dit ouais c'est dans
les missions régionales ou régional mais
pas du tout c'est une maison d'édition
qui fonctionne très très bien qui est
dirigé de main de maître par jean pierre
il ya publié 80 romans policiers ont ces
romans policiers son héroïne s'appelle
marie l'espère
quand un livre démarre moyennement il en
vend 80 villes relativement patron de
midi mais sa première et à barrie on est
là dans une maison ex amant florissant
et qui font tout cas très bien donc
c'est une honte revient seulement il ya
une autre raison qui est très bien pour
les pour les polars c'est la maison
lajoinie alors parlez nous de ce
troisième choix que vous faites de
dominique bourgeon coup de folie
c'est un roman policier mais pas que
alors moins de 2 minutes 1
le second de notre maison déniant tout
cas cette collection parce qu'il a une
intrigue policière bien évidemment il
n'y a pas que çà et là notamment
dominique bourgeon nous emmène au fin
fond de la lozère dans des paysages
absolument sublime nous raconte
l'histoire de deux gendarmes un peu
promet dans cette dans cette campagne
absolument charmante mais effectivement
par moments un peu désolé alors qu'un
peu désertique mais y adjoint à cette
histoire des deux gendarmes des crimes
absolument horrible mais l'intérêt est
tout l'intérêt du durement repose aussi
sur le l'intrusion de toute une bande de
vieux anarchie réfugier dans l'est les
causes de la lozère et qui sont qui
semble guider par la police meurtrière
d'une dune d'une curieuse meurtrière et
donc ta maison des rapports historiques
vraiment intéressant sur l'histoire de
l'anarchie sur les gardiens des
questions à paris et puis sur celle d'un
art qui sont venus s'exiler se calmer en
le vert et qui sont retrouvés des
remparts une heure dans une meurtrière
qui semble tellement tragique
deuxième hic vient d'écrire et de
dominique bourges on est vraiment un
auteur à suivre assurément le personnage
et deux gendarmes
il faut pas entendre c'est assez
original que normalement les gendarmes
c'est toujours débout
les bonhommes jaunes de la campagne
qu'on imagine fréquemment ventripotent
et c'est hélas ce sont deux jeunes
femmes
oui une nouvelle gendarmerie qui arrive
mais ça merci beaucoup merci vous on
changera je dis donc ça s'appelle coup
de folie de 2010 gourgeon il y avait
aussi pierre bouchard et l'assassin qui
aimait polbos et puis évidemment john
kennedy
o'toole la conjuration des imbéciles
merci beaucoup aussi valérie des tuiles
nathalie vous avez des conseils je
trouve votre foi merci à tous
et à très vite pour un nouveau numéro d'
envies de lecture
[Musique]